avec un tee shirt et le but c'est de le
transformer en débardeur avec une manche
avec une seule manche donc un tiers
comportait pas pour pouvoir le
réutiliser la tendance up cycling s'est
emparé de parly 2 le centre commercial
installé aux chaînés rocancourt organise
un atelier samedi 2 avril l'objectif du
jour repenser un t-shirt pièces
classiques que l'on trouve dans tous les
dressings en lui donnant une seconde vie
pour guider les participants l'insta
gras meuse ruby pigeon spécialiste de la
pratique c'est une bonne manière
d'apprendre assez rapidement les déjà
stress d'esprit des transformations et
en plus des bases de couture pour
qu'elle puisse le faire et puis j'ai
toujours attention à laquelle vous êtes
vraiment tout compris et qu'elle puisse
le faire à la maison après sans moi quoi
l'astuce c'est what d'avoir le temps à
ne pas avoir peur de se tromper et de
prendre des tissus clair parce que ça
permet de voir où est ce que le fils var
quatre personnes ont pu participer à
cette animation sélectionnés grâce à un
concours sur instagram lancée par le
centre commercial plus qu'une tendance
loeb cycling est pour elle une nouvelle
manière de consommer afin de lutter
contre le gaspillage
on souhaite réellement mettre en avant
la mode responsable qui est un
engagement qui nous tient vraiment à
coeur ça fait très longtemps que je fais
très attention à ma consommation que
j'achète des vêtements de seconde main
mais
je
ne sais pas encore
les reprendre ce qu'ils
apprennent donc là c'était une première
démarche
super intéressante pour moi le pseye
kling compte de plus en plus d'adeptes
en france où le gaspillage est encore
bien présent sur 600 mille tonnes de
textiles vendus moins d'un quart se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans les cycles de
recyclage moi je pense que tout est ok
claouey après c'est vrai que ça n'a rien
à voir avec les à outrance si tu vas pas
utiliser le but quand même derrière
c'est c'est que ça soit utilisé long
terme et que et que ce soit par excès
finissent à la poubelle quand simplement